[Music]
we're so excited you could join us on
twitch youtube facebook and periscope
and we're going to be joined by conan
o'brien here in a second but first we
start with the true stars of conan
berlin uh
uh flulaborg
that's right
hello right and writer jesse gaskell and
writer jose arroyo these are the people
who are and of course of course yeah
these are the people that actually made
the episode funny and great and conan
just kind of coasted a lot riding our
coat they built the red cadillac and he
just got it or the small what was that
small car call
that's right uh and uh make sure to
watch the show tonight at 10 9 central
on tbs uh and this is actually exciting
because this is the first time we've
done a live q a where people have not
seen the episode yet oh so this is very
cool very cool but these are all
spoilers these are all spoilers welcome
to the spoileriffic does conan live or
die in this episode nobody knows nobody
knows uh but first of all flula uh let's
quickly talk about what you're wearing
absolutely i love this man uh fashion
icon fashion forward
[Music]
yeah
would you like something good no no okay
they're in my pants
as many as you like
yeah i did wake up like this and just
without the shoes
you did tell me it was not a formal time
okay
all right all right all right
that's right
say hi to the internet conan internet
which one is my camera uh it's i mean
they're both your cameras they're all
you paid for all of them this is your
show yes i own everything here welcome
internet uh oh hello flo good day
brian what are you drinking there a nice
it's a beverage delicious liquid okay a
warm beer that's all i want to know it's
warm in the morning it is warm in the
morning very nice very nice good to be
here sorry i'm running a little bit late
that's okay this is me pretty much
without makeup
a light powder sorry internet
so conan we're talking about conan
berlin which is airing tonight at 10.
you're shouting again i'm sorry i'm just
very excited to see you uh no you're not
um
i could hear you
i parked my car about
600 yards from this building and i could
hear aaron blair yelling his questions
uh
literally there are just excited emojis
spilling out of your face
so let's all calm down all right sorry
you seem calm i'm trying okay it's all
inside you know you shove it down shove
it down shut it down and then it goes
right here into your lips and then you
zip it and eat it in the night time what
is the german word for this uh
schnufflepak okay
awful
conan uh
how did conan berlin come about how did
you decide to go to berlin well we love
doing these travel shows uh we've been
to a lot of great places and
uh always looking for
a reason to go to a new fun uh city a
place i've never been
and flula was on the show and we hit it
off right away we did we did uh and um
and then flula said you must come to
berlin and i said i'd love to come to
berlin that's really all i need if you
send me some snacks or just ask me to go
to your country
that's pretty much all i need i'm an
easy lay and so um
i said yes
and berlin is a perfect city for us
because it's so different
so much is happening there uh right now
it's so in the news uh it is so
vibrant it is uh really a big player in
the world scene and i thought we gotta
go we gotta check it out
awesome and uh actually somebody from
facebook asked not to skip ahead but how
would you rate german beer
oh uh i gotta tell you it's fantastic
but it is beer i mean
i'm not a connoisseur of beers what i'm
just telling you that it's beer and yes
is it better than budweiser yes it's
better than budweiser but i'm not gonna
say that i you know if i went to a bar
here in los angeles and asked for a beer
on tap would it taste vastly inferior to
what i had in germany
i thought it was good beer
um so and somebody else from facebook
asked uh you know what would you say
your favorite dish was in berlin you
guys had lunch together as part of the
episode oh that was good what were some
of your favorites well it's the first i
like all of the voices we had some nice
joyful which way
shoulder shoulder of the piggy yes yes
wrenched shoulder of the pig
yes
shoulder some schnitzel of course uh
schnitzel is fun to say more fun to say
than it is to eat i would say it is a
splits
uh yes uh i have to say i loved the
sausages
what do you call them worst yes
many types
of many types what kinds of types of
voice we had eisenhower with us
and stout we didn't have two glitches
said to me that when i'm speaking fake
german
and i know nothing of german uh language
but you've said about every sixth word
is i actually say something yeah you
just said it is on i just said it's on
top of this you just said
which means on top of the store so yeah
we are eating we are eating uh some
wasps on top of a 7-eleven at this
moment yeah it's 18 to 33 percent you
say real words yes
griezer
the heist is hot okay yeah the clipper
is set so you have the flu so you have i
am hot with the flu hot with the flu
it's that easy to speak german and
you've got to do this with your voice
optional but always improving yes always
improving let me do a quick shout out i
know that flulas probably made it all
about himself he does
suck the oxygen or shouting seton out of
the room
but uh jesse gaskell jose arroyo they
are the
juggernaut or juggernaut
they are the uh head of the spear they
they go to these uh cities they do the
research and they really make it happen
i once again i have to applaud them they
are fearless they are intrepid um they
do an amazing job and they make these
shows uh i think really uh happen sorry
i applaud them both absolutely
and actually somebody on facebook
actually asked and this is for you guys
did you find german humor to be
different than american and how so
oh wow uh germans had a good sense of
humor they do oh yeah dude
that's good to hear i didn't lose for me
we always do really well when there's a
good contrast for us especially with
because conan interacting one-on-one
with people is what really generates i
think a lot of our
best moments and we had so many good
people there good characters because
people are very comfortable being
themselves
they're very like self-assured and
confident and i think that that
contrasts with conan
i mean
a terrible put down but also
that i think jesse's right that uh when
we were at the nude beach
one of the most interesting things was
the guy that looks a lot like sting uh
there's we interact with someone he
looks like a nude sting yeah and i've
seen a nude sting and um
uh we had a 36-hour tantric session once
together yeah well he was doing
everything i was just watching
did he show you his message in a bottle
all right i don't like it i don't like
your humor no
you know what is that no no no no no
it doesn't help to just open your mouth
afterwards like a muppet and look around
okay now listen i'll get to you later
all i'm saying is uh that
there's a nude man that we encountered
and he was the most comfortable person
i've ever spoken to
and completely nude multiple penises he
had several yeah and uh i never felt
more clothed in my life i've just i need
to be close so he was literally my
opposite i was talking to my opposite
yeah in every way he was german uh i'm
this irish american uh he is nude i am
clothed yeah his hippie is out your pp
is inside my ep is actually
it's in it's i have an innie oh yes
no inadvertently you said the right
thing which is my penis goes up into a
cavity does this cause a vagina normally
it is a vagina yes
the doctor said uh i was raised as a boy
i have a vagina this is wonderful yeah
this is where we learn things um we
actually uh the show is not aired yet
but we do have a clip of the nude beach
so uh take a look right now a quick clip
of conan and flula feeling uncomfortable
in new beach this is the first time i've
been to a nude beach how do you feel
it's a little strange i have to say you
look around and a lot of men walking and
they have their what do the germans call
it penis
did you mean that always good to learn a
new language i mean look you turn right
there and there's a man's ass we're
looking right into that man's ass and
it's just you know like have you not
seen a man's anus before i mean i i have
seen it yes
there's another one okay
we have a quick round of applause for
flawless torso oh this guy
is cut
you're you looked fantastic there's a
graphic t-shirt i've ordered that is
what i was wearing i would say that you
immediately your packs will look
delicious
i could have used help there's a reason
i didn't take off my shirt
next time although you'll see plenty of
me uh when i go and visited dominatrix
that's the show and um
i may have gone too far in that segment
that is the farthest i've ever seen you
go
in any comedy you're fearless in your
comedy that that is beyond anything i've
ever seen you do and i actually admired
you because
what the audience
won't see
is tremendous and you should go online
if you hopefully the web has extras and
stuff you were like
chuck yeager of comedy just going as far
as you could
i asked you i am a married man do you my
wife has not seen this yet will this
cause me problems uh no in the marital
chamber
none that don't already exist i think
you're fine nicely done i think you're
nicely done jose arroyo has the eyes he
has two poached eggs
i have no that's not really it is true
he looks like a fish that's been trapped
by and is losing oxygen i'm actually
squinting right now so he's got i don't
know aren't you talking about guys i've
ever seen right
what what tell us about the dummy for
those of us who haven't seen a
dominatrix in the room and uh at home
what was that like a great thing that i
think makes that segment uh kind of
fascinating is that the dominatrix is
not there for comedy
she is not there to be in a comedy scene
she's there to do what she does right
i'm there for comedy and what happens is
she really does want to take off all my
clothes and put things into me
and i really don't want that to happen
and it's a
the whole thing is a battle she's trying
to get and sometimes she's winning and
sometimes i'm pushing back
and it was kind of harrowing and my team
was really frightened because they kept
trying to tell her this is for comedy
and she kept saying i don't care
i don't care who this man is i don't
care you know if he has a tv show i do
what i do she had a very uh german i
think sense of i must do my task now yes
and i'm trying to stop her
and man it's and it really hurt yes and
we didn't we actually didn't determine a
safe word i think in advance i don't
think she had one
yeah i don't think she has this woman
was going to do what she was going to do
and it was uh
terrifying and exhilarating at the same
time and i did learn a lot about what i
don't like sexually okay i learned a lot
about that
nipple twisting just hurts i don't see
any i'm just giving that i'm just
putting that out there if anyone's into
that please tell me
why
what it's all about because this woman
would do something that hurts and then
rub my back a little and see see
there is the pain but then the pleasure
okay and i was like no
just rub the back don't don't do that
that really hurts no but it is both now
i understand now do you do you
understand the nipple twisting no it is
a painful thing but sometimes people are
like hey it's time for pain no pains no
gains just like the film with marcus
wahlberg and the rock
there's no
is there a movie called no pains no
gains yeah i'm thinking of boys in the
hood oh okay you catch it yeah when you
just add a z to things it's a boy that's
usually boys
shout out
[Laughter]
she doesn't need a shout out
he's doing fine well actually maybe he
could use it no i haven't seen snow dogs
okay okay is it snow dogs d-o-g-z i do
not in germany we always are adding more
esses and things right so i don't know
what it was like here on the state side
okay
all right very nice to see what kind of
tv do you get in did you grow up
watching in in germany did you see a lot
of mr belvedere we see all of the old
times so i did see cheers for the first
time in 1999. we did receive it it's
norm and the beers you know norman the
mailman is there
[Laughter]
that's a different thing it's frasier
well it's not spelled
okay listen you're in our country now i
don't care what your pants say
they are silent and you know what's
coming you'll never get lost in a cave
that's for sure is there a cave in your
studio
a german word no but it sounds it right
it really does
yeah it's uh it sounds fantastic thank
you it's the sound a german spoon makes
when it drops into hot soup
your mind work is either terrible or
great
i like when you yeah soup it's a chili
oh what's this a lasagna okay
one of the fans asked how fast did you
drive in the audubon now when you visit
the autobahn first of all it's the
autobahn thank you thank
you yes how fast did you drive on the
i think i went i don't remember because
they haven't converted to our system yet
you guys would know but what was my top
speed i think i hit like 150 miles an
hour
144 miles an hour yes right right
incredibly fast yes i went very fast
i felt safe the whole time because i was
in a beautiful
bmw
oh here we go that's the bmw
i8 now i don't have one
and if anyone at bmw is watching
and you want to send me it's one of the
things the doors go up like
yeah
and uh then you get in and the doors go
puss
on the clothes yes but the truth goes
yeah and uh it's an amazing car the bmw
i8 i don't have one but
but bavarian motor works are you
watching if you're watching
you know what they'll do is they'll send
me one plus a bill for 250
that's how i get things in show business
i put a give a little shout out and they
send it to me with a bill and when i
work it out it's more than what an
average person paid that it sounds just
yeah i like that do you guys have the
euro you have the euro
you have the euro we have it we actually
do you miss the mark i missed it the
deutsche mark is so sad
what is it it's a mark it's a mark of
what sassy times okay it's not i get it
huge waste of time
huge waste of time i always i know less
about germany after talking to
you well you create a vacuum of
knowledge about germany but are you not
listening i'm telling you all the facts
and feelings as well
it's like a poem uh
one of my favorite things about going to
uh berlin yeah was that uh we all
started singing a lot of falco
and we sang a lot of [ __ ] because
i've always loved falco now there's a
lot of young people out there they're
like what are these old men talking
about falco look it up falco rock me
amadeus f-a-l-c-o
falco and he was great because he had
that he was falco yeah and he was rap he
was one of the first
and only german rappers of the 80s of
the 80s he's the kanye west of
there austria go there we go
well played no photos he was fantastic
he's not with us anymore he's passed on
to the other realm but uh shout out to
falco go look at his videos and also 99
luftpalu
i've always wanted to meet because i
still have a huge crush on her you must
meet me now you must hang out she's
touring yeah i would love to meet nina
she said you and i and our little
toys with the money we got shouts and
fleets
[Music]
team coco on snapchat you could actually
see everyone uh jamming out on the bus
to those songs because things got things
get a little loopy loopy on those uh
they did yeah we spent a lot of time
together you can watch us you can watch
way too much of us there's a lot of
extras yeah i think you can see me
driving very fast in the autobahn and
360. yes which is pretty crazy because
you can see the urine spread
and then the sheer uh speed which i'm
going the urine is is pulled back and it
actually turns into a pretty good wine
you actually said the driver it's funny
because the driver who is a professional
obviously was you know uh 100 confident
he was driving but you said he got a
little he is a professional
driver for bmw this is what he does he
is the comp he's like a fighter pilot
yes and he was terrified when i was
driving and you could see it in in three
seconds you can see cause i really i
shouldn't be driving uh i should not be
seeing a dominatrix and i should not be
driving the bmw i9 that's no speeds um
one thing uh that we uh that one of my
favorite uh parts of the show was when i
kind of went to go make a certain kind
of sausage what particular kind of
sausage i don't remember blood uh blood
blood sausage
and uh and tell us a little bit about
that the guy again it's all about
finding the right people
and we went to this
he's a uh
mark marcus spencer marcus spencer he is
a master
a meister
he's a meister he is he is one of the
world's best sausage makers
and uh
he
is uh considered
i think worldwide to be one of the best
and what's great about him is that he
again was very onto his task and he
loves his job he loves his job and again
like the dominatrix he's just doing his
job and i'm doing everything i can
to ruin it
to stop it to make it go wrong and
that's again you get the nice
the nice back and forth push me pull you
of him just having it's constantly
feeding you raw meat and you trying to
not to take it and at one point on
camera you see him realize that i've
been cheating him
[Laughter]
he's i think very disappointed uh
but it was it was fantastic it was
really good and there was again a nice
dynamic it got very creepy when he took
me down to where they make the sausage
which was like half underground in a
weird yeah you know what it looked like
it looked like a scene from the first
movie hostile
it looked like it all starts off with i
felt like a very pretty
co-ed traveling who suddenly is in a
terrible situation that's right uh and
we also did a little bit of serious uh
uh serious work there we went and
visited uh some refugees at uh temple
hoff uh and um was there what surprised
you about going to see uh all those
great people there well we wanted to you
know whenever we go on these trips
obviously
job number one is make comedy and and
try and uh have a lot of fun and um
trying the mission statement of these
shows is i really want those people
laughing at me right i would like the
joke to be
uh you're the fool i'm the fool yeah
which is pretty easy
but uh
i like to uh try a lot of things get in
over my head and let people laugh at me
that is the goal of of these shows but
another goal of these shows is to
uh also not sort of turn a blind eye to
what's really happening there and uh
and and i think we've so far been able
to
capture that there was
um some really sweet moments in the cube
show
in the armenia show when i went with
sona
um we at the show ended with you know
this actually one of the most powerful
things i've been associated with
in my career on television was going uh
to the uh genocide
uh memorial with her and it was very
real we just rolled the cameras it
wasn't and and and experienced that and
the same thing with our trip to north
korea when i went with uh steven yun and
went up to uh the dmz and you could just
feel the raw power of and sadness and
tragedy of what's happening there
and you just let it let that moment play
for a second and on this trip we wanted
to uh
germany has really led the way in the
refugee crisis and it's such i mean we
taped this episode in september i think
and who knew but with our election and
uh and with our president-elect
this whole question of others and this
xenophobia and this concern about
you know who we don't want these people
too many of these kinds of people and it
was really fascinating because germany
has led the way in europe and uh angela
merkel i think deserves a lot of credit
she she
uh invited many refugees and took them
in and they're housed at tempelhof
airport which is this massive german
airport which is now closed uh i think
since the late 80s or 90s
and there's a lot of refugees there and
they're waiting
to maybe get better housing uh somewhere
in europe or germany and
so there were a ton of refugees there
that we met and talked to they had a
group that we spoke to and i think they
were from i'm trying to remember where
they were from syria
afghanistan palestine palestine and it
was really interesting because you get
in a room with them
and they're young men they're kids some
of them yeah and
they are
they're uh you're with them and you're
like is this what when you're in a room
with these people
you they're suddenly not those people
they're just they're not a label they're
not a label they're just i mean it
sounds cliche but
we
i spoke to them a little bit and they
just want to go back to their country
they just can't because if they do
they'll be killed and so uh they
they very much want their countries to
heal so that they can go back there
there they don't they're not their dream
is not to live someplace else they want
to go back to their homeland
and um
they're really remarkable people and
they're sweet and they're funny and we
we ended up playing badminton and and
yeah there's some nice comedy moments
with them that were very natural and
then at the end they were
destroying me in badminton and they were
cheering and taunting me and it was nice
it was nice to that they could beat up
on me a little bit and they immediately
got the humor of it and enjoyed it and
so that was
that was a great moment yeah to put kind
of faces and names to to kind of a a
situation is always to kind of humanize
a crisis is really great um and we're
gonna kind of wrap up here very soon but
i just like to kind of go down the line
and say a few things that didn't maybe
make the show but were highlights of the
trip because again we we go on these
trips and they're just absolutely crazy
and we're working all the time but we
can't shove it all into into a show
right so were there any personal
highlights that you guys had aside from
hanging out with conan and flula which
is always a blind oh well conan was
outside of the parliament building and
just then the
president of the parliament goes by in a
car oh yeah that's right and conan goes
oh that's the president of the
parliament he'll probably want to speak
to me and the car pulls out faster and
harder
and then you just go so maybe later
as the car peels away that was that was
very funny and it is a lot of the great
moments i think of these shows kind of
to jesse's point are
unscripted moments that just kind of
happen yeah like all of a sudden just
bumped into this motorcade and conan
makes a moment out of it right right
yeah absolutely jesse well i there's a
clip you'll see where conan's trying to
get into this nightclub it's the brigane
yeah it's the it's the most exclusive
club in europe and
um i won't tell you whether he's able to
get in or not but we had some fun going
to nightclubs and there was this that
nightclub we went to with sado opera was
one of the most amazing clubs i've ever
seen it was like five levels of rooms
and there was one room that was just
like
it was basically a giant vagina that you
walked into the villa renata yeah
yeah and conan played with a band called
sato opera yes uh who's kind of like
what would you say how would you
describe them oh my god kind of sexy
kiss yeah
goth mime craziness uh
yeah and i was and they're very
they're very about gender fluidity and
there was a lot of grabbing of my
areas again a lot of that happened
yeah the nightclub scene was really fun
yeah and i also love that germans don't
dance with each other they stand all in
lines and face the dj and just dance
that's true that's true it's just it's
more of like a concert rather than like
a a get down a dance circle yeah i
believe you tried to dance with somebody
i did try i tried to dance with a girl
and and she literally just wouldn't look
at me which is typical so that was fun
it actually wasn't any different than
dancing in america uh
you and conan spent a lot of time
one-on-one together a lot of fans out
there want to know what is that like
what is it like to spend time with the
man himself well conan is a busy
bumblebee as you guys say and so he was
stupid
well i can tell you uh in the mornings
so
conan doesn't know this so i'm telling
everyone for the first time um you
dropped one of your hotel keycards in
the lobby and i picked it up and so
every morning i would uh because i am
adjusted to the time more quickly than
you i would go into your room did you
hear me whispering the song where have
all the cowboys gone from the 1990s i
thought that was a dream no that was me
that was you yeah yeah 6 30 every
morning
so and so you would stand over my
sleeping body yes i started from two
meters away and every night i would
improve by 30 centimeters so the final
night we were very close very close
i had these most amazing dreams when i
was in berlin and now i know why
yeah yeah incredible dr quinn medicine
woman okay
again terrible reference
you know i spent so much time with flula
and there's a lot of it i mean there's a
lot of it it's on camera then there's a
lot of it's not on camera but we would
just uh we would be walking around we
would we spent a lot of time uh
there was a a roof bar or beer garden on
the top of our hotel and we would just
hang out there
and and uh
and have
they had a sign a special drink there
berlin yeah
like you've heard of a moscow mule they
had a berlin mule and it came in a
copper cup oh yeah and uh we would drink
those and look out at the city uh it was
a lot of drinking uh but it was fun it
was a really good time and flula
um is so much fun
uh sincerely just so much fun as you can
see to just hang out with he's like this
all the time and so there's about nine
hours that isn't even on camera of him
being really funny and we will just do
this nonsense with each other
the cameras aren't even rolling and
we're just
going and i felt like well the easiest
show in the world would be if we could
just have like gopros and it was just
fool and i and we shot we could shoot
like 35 hours a you know a day yeah
but i really do feel like we would just
roll on everything and you would never
run out of
terrible clothes to wear and i don't
mean to insult you no this is a
compliment
he has an endless supply of uh
sweatshirts and t-shirts that have
kittens
uh possums yes all of the animals and
also extinct animals yes you have not
seen my brontosaurus jeans
you know true story i told you this but
when i was in college there was a kid
that showed up who was from germany he
was an exchange student and his name was
gregor gruber
[Laughter]
and this is a true story he showed up i
think junior year of college and he
showed up and i remembered you know this
is in the 1980s but he shows up and he
was wearing a pair of jeans i've never
seen before or since
the jeans were green
except the crotch panel was a bright
yellow
and he was gregor gruber and i remember
just thinking there's gregor gruber
wearing his green pants with what looked
like it was all just one pair of pants
but with the yellow crotch panel
and it blew my mind and i realized he
was probably your father yeah
he's out there somewhere gregor if
you're out there reach out to me you
were very nice i remembered he was very
nice yeah i like gregor grouper i'm not
putting him down i still hope you have
those jeans because i will buy them for
sixty five thousand dollars or thirty
five thousand right marks
too soon
and and finally youtube uh somebody on
youtube asked where's the next trip
where are we thinking and going next
well we might as well tell them now yeah
let's hear it new york city oh how much
footage of new york city
we're gonna go it's the island of
manhattan very exotic
a place where uh i think there's very
little footage
we're gonna go to the chrysler building
uh no we don't know where we're gonna go
yet what are things that attract you to
to certain countries what are things
that excite you uh in a country besides
never having been there i like never
having been there and i like there being
a strong contrast and so far everywhere
we've gone there's been a strong
contrast meaning i'm a fish out of water
so uh you know um i'm
i don't fit in and culturally physically
whatever you want to say and uh and so
that that is what uh attracts me yeah
and so uh and i do think i don't see why
you only have to come along to berlin i
do think
why can't even if i go to guam please
why can't we be there why can't or at
least make an appearance
flue is going to be the where's waldo of
our travel show
meaning i swear to god i think it would
be a really good idea if just wherever i
am in the world if i'm in the arctic
yeah you just if you have to look
carefully in the background in an igloo
holding a penguin to find you you think
so in the arctic yes okay i feel like
those pants i feel like so i would pack
these pants and put them on my head they
look warm also i think you're always
wearing those pants under whatever pants
you're wearing you have noticed i'm a
baggy cathy
i worry about you
i'm very concerned about you well thank
you guys for joining us you can follow
flula at flula on facebook twitter
instagram youtube follow this man this
man's worth following he's very funny
and please watch conan burleigh tonight
ten nine seven
that's the whole point of doing this and
you just swallowed
the whole party
you enunciated go to watch flula and
then the whole point of this is to get
people to watch the episode tonight
anyways
that's uh uh conan berlin 10 p.m 9
central
on tbs followed by an all-new conan with
jake gyllenhaal ronda rousey and the
robert
glasper experiment
we're going to show tonight on uh the
conan that airs after yes uh we're going
to air a lot of stuff that's not in the
episode oh awesome
more footage
and you can also see all kinds of extra
goodies at teamcoco.com berlin uh as
well as the episode and thank you for
joining us everybody jose arroyo jesse
gaskell aboard of course conan o'brien
thank you for joining us twitch youtube
facebook uh and periscope follow us on
every social platform imaginable at team
coco we will see you guys not both
tonight conan berlin 10 p.m gbs